hey wait CJ what Oh see fast play rain
dripping off bad balls man I'm back baby
enough no Oh Willie then we got to
finish this the old-fashioned way
yeah with balls
hello welcome to soccer physics we had
Wade messed it all up last time so we
have to start again so we're gonna play
and we're gonna be experts at it or I'm
gonna be experts added and then Wade's
gonna be an embarrassment to his entire
race Oh could you
what happened glued me well your hue
middle there are reefs
yes it is human race you and race see
her graces noises don't you move racist
prick let's play Wow
hey we're gonna get into a heavy social
aah oh you know a heavy socio-economic
debate here
oh very fullest off oh look you get out
of the girls play some guys hook of
attacker
I'm coming her fruitball dog oh wow like
I do it haha
no no look hey how's it going hey are
you doing I'm doing good every I'm glad
we got risk it looks like this no I'm
coming to assist you're not the only is
on the way oh my god no no no no would
you lead a push okay gently no we're all
very gentle to push you oh god I'm not
this situation literally doing nothing
but practicing oh my goodness waiting
for this day to arrive oh this is not
going well this is exactly how it
usually goes with me when I play so yes
it is kid it any baggage y'all they met
aims that we didn't play on now when
[ __ ] okay just let you do your thing and
I'll win no then it's boring video who
gotta do something I'm coming to assist
from behind from behind from their [ __ ]
oh come on links okay here we go
Oh what I'm Scottie both of our goalies
are just doing hand
other not helping no yeah okay oh my god
hold on whoa hold on God
hold on a goddamn second we do think she
talked this out okay we're here when
when wet although we lay this dear came
down I've got my goal is T epitome for
the third week I've got Jackson hands
stand behind me he doesn't want anything
to do with this 3sum we're about to have
but you just listen to me if you let me
win I'll let you have Jackson hmm I'd
like that Oh
his brother Jerry Hanson all right okay
oh we have to reach an impasse somewhere
yeah if you let me with top do stop
doing your dance or else my guys out
there he goes oh oh go
is it an interpretive dance hour oh oh
no don't stand what you had to love
we're no moon get into our superpose uh
well jazzy Jerry and Stan's gonna talk
talk through his legs for a little bit
here oh wait you're Jerry sorry
wait that was Jerry this Jackson no oh
that Jason this is Jason Jerry Jack's
really confusing cuz their names are
both Jerry Jason Jackson at a different
order this is Janet Jackson Jason can't
stand and that's Jerry jacks [ __ ] you
dude I didn't think that's all ah whoa
yes please so dude yes Oh God check to
Jerry
it'sit's tiny gesture at age 8 what up
hello Oh Oliver
let's thank you oh oh whoa whoa I've
never seen no head mode have I uh why do
we not have heads I'm not sure I don't
remember [ __ ] okay yeah we seem to be a
lot more balanced moment well I'm coming
in for this Hey look I'm Michael
headstand I'm Billy
not
even without a head Jerry hey baby uh
okay thank God
oh okay all right wait hey I want to
talk about peace oh I'll get the home
for a moment I mean forget our amazing
beat okay I'm telling you hang on there
we go oh no no no no no no no you you
always sound like an immature little
baby whenever you lose it no no no no no
ball game I go no no where those coming
from don't know okay
what party cuz I won cuz I'm amazing as
I predicted at the beginning of this
wait is an embarrassment to the entire
human race even aliens wouldn't want
anything to do with them except to
experimental dissect him and see how he
can possibly be so terrible in fact in
the future cuz I can predict that the
aliens are gonna catch you find that
your pun glands stop it's me you're
pathetically puny Puntland is gonna be
protruding from your sternum and the
aliens are gonna poke you with pincers
and fight that your puns while your pun
gland might be protruding and pustule
are you insane I'm telling a cautionary
tale tell the tale I'm so wet all right
so it's me if I win this next one if
it's best two out of three I win forever
is that true we got let's do a three
good yeah does this take a slow prologue
this I said slight yeah all right so on
three we're gonna hit all of our buttons
at that time let's just let fate decide
okay three two one no joke not for me
look go no one would move
it's so stupid whoa whoa coming over
there okay up all right yep here we go
epic defense no oh I just gotta touch it
I just have to touch it ah vodka yeah
you're good you're good I'm on my way
no go to score hang on wait I'm gonna
stay on the car race I'm covered
technical foul
thank you for kicking me in the butt
that's not what I meant to do I meant to
smash my face yeah all right you're
getting you're getting school today I'm
coming to tell you everybody going back
now coming that you can't beat this
leaning tower soccer here Wow oh damn it
whoa no no no I hate the beach balls
they never okay maybe I Shh it's okay
just let it happen
Shh yeah let it stop stop stop yes here
we go yeah oh I'm sorry of you oh yeah
okay yeah I was trying to 69 you but I
couldn't figure out how to do it
correctly nope oh um all right I'm
coming back ah no penalty kick head
stand get it epic reliving here yeah oh
yeah yeah goalie you're doing nothing
for me well I lost our heads again
yep okay oh why yes get in this goal
apparently that's coming for it
yeah whoever won just a classroom
humanity forever whatever used to what I
said I said whoever wins this game like
if it's best two out of three I won the
first one if I won the next game I would
have won the series you do sports how do
you not understand the I'll do these
sports
soccer yeah okay
all right this is ones for all the beans
wheat beans we don't expression I don't
eat an expression of beans is up that's
up she calls like a bunch of apples no
that's not whoa that's not exactly to
see I patented the the rocket technique
I learned it from Shaolin oh my good my
face shall amongst all the more than
shocked race oh I'll get in there okay
uh-huh
use me pardon me I just want to learn
how tough you guys get this in your
deathly working I've got a special
delivery front oh just hey hey good try
me
good try oh I did ah [ __ ] never oh my
face is it good oh I'm coming back down
you got out I got you Scott Starling
incredible the man the legend the beans
no have you ever seen that video no
Scott Starling we gotta watch that video
okay we're gonna watch that video that's
literally we'll really big can we do
it's my channel I'll do what I want
Scott Stirling here comes nerves of
steel that man winding up for the shot
and the cannon has fired and hit
Stirling directly the banks still
waiting for the kick to happen it's
probably wondering when
frankly is a gimmick he literally just
has to kick it anywhere except we're
selling its mercy that should be begging
thing it's Becky that should be begging
for him so where were we
I don't carting over apparently all
right this one this one was for all the
beam all the B's one was for all the
beam all the big welcome back everybody
to the intermission it's over scotch
styling okay to it this one's for all
the beans now that we're in the proper
proper was until I had to adjust so I
wouldn't pull out some rain guards
that's a gimme for you because I know
I'm so confident in my [ __ ] hello are
you okay didn't we must have a very good
one
I've got a I've got great [ __ ] if you
I've got the best [ __ ] in the world you
know all the women in the world when I'm
in there well she just might you know
I'm railing my inside there I'll just
let that ended really [ __ ] battle oh
my when I'm plowing cuz I haven't moving
oh my god you're why nothin when I plow
my 17 inch [ __ ] inside there hahahaha
you're thinking I was good knows enough
is bad I shoulda do I don't know I'm
gonna try to scoot it
I don't think footballs over row like
hat no no no all right so good thing I
can cut out this why is my guy moving
away because it snowed dude come on
okay why do I always get in this
predicament hello I was good when I
started this hey ah ah all right this is
the last you get yeah haha oh Jesus
ah you're gonna eat some it's all
already covered great to eat some ball
your that predicament again er no I'm
not
shut up you don't know my predicaments
okay so I get over here I get over here
hey this guy ha there we go
ha now you're in a predicament of the
original place before we kick the ball
where's in between the both of us so yes
II oh no oh damn it oh thank you I
didn't want the huge goals anyway I just
like standard mano-a-mano
I burped leaves all the beans Oh beans
ah
watch that video again this shop okay so
that was soccer physics Wade won I mean
if you even want to count that as a win
not really thank you everybody for
watching that was soccer physics glad
you could join us for another round and
maybe we'll meet back up in a few months
when you come back out to LA yeah thanks
so much Wade for being dizzy for me and
thank you everybody so much for watching
let us know what you thought of our
soccer adventures down in the comments
below and check the description for that
video we're watching thanks again
everybody
as always we'll see you every comment
flip upside down and nestled in my head
I think I need to go right when I need
to go left I'm gonna video so maybe you
should just give me a trance